we can get this down to numbers 20,000
and below that's a good outcome in terms
of where we would hope to get to with
this outbreak 20,000 deaths the hope for
lockdown now shattered the latest
figures show the UK's coronavirus toll
is twice that more than 40,000 by far
the highest in Europe this professor of
Public Health says lockdown came too
late
most of these deaths were entirely
avoidable I think it was late action
late Awareness a lack of interest of
what was going on around the world and
not listening to the advice from w-h-o
and the European Centre for disease
prevention and control I'm not learning
from the experience of other countries
who had experienced it in the weeks and
it arrived on our Shore the UK's
epidemic hasn't just been bigger it's
lasted longer hospital admissions of
patients with kovat 19 peaked at more
than 3,100 a day at the beginning of
April in the two weeks that followed
they more than halved to 1500 but the
rate of decline has slowed in the last
week it's been barely perceptible there
are still more than 400 admissions a day
one reason may be that the virus which
has driven up deaths so sharply in care
homes compared to hospitals and private
homes is taking longer to fall in
residential settings and could be
receding the outbreak in the wider
community but other experts say the
lockdown itself was too relaxed the way
in which the lockdown has been
approached in the UK hasn't been a
strict or as far as in other countries
I'd say it has been a bit more of a
house hearted approach to a lockdown
than we've seen in other countries where
they've seen a lot stronger enforcement
and perhaps a lot more emphasis and
clarity in the message that was given to
the public here it's almost like asking
people to do things but I think in other
countries the approach has been much
clearer that this was a national
emergency
eight thousand people a day are still
catching kovat 19 but barely a quarter
of them attested and isolated even the
government's chief scientist has urged
caution as ministers lift layer after
layer of the lockdown
whether that's let the virus loose once
again when be known until at least next
week Thomas More Sky News